do you think a Trump getting re-elected
is that a good thing or bad thing for
the cryptocurrency world or is it
irrelevant it's irrelevant in a lot of
ways because no government as we've
talked about has the power to stop
Bitcoin or any group of governments you
know the question is comes up a what if
governments you know outlaw Bitcoin what
happens then nothing because the bitcoin
is uncompensated well for one thing it's
it's it it's unsensible and it's not
going to be plus all these government
regulators and politicians are paid and
fiat money right so you know every
revolution what happens is the
regulators and government officials end
up becoming a fifth column you know
during the revolution because they they
kind of sell out the revolution inside
and you see that with any any
governments that try to go after Bitcoin
there's gonna be plenty of people in
that government we're gonna be buying
Bitcoin because they're being paid at
fiat money and the fiat money is
collapsing you know it's the story the
Roman Empire right they try to pay their
soldiers and ever-diminishing amounts of
silver until they soldiers started you
know working with the Vandals and they
and and the barbarians this is the saint
gonna be the same story because the
bitcoins hard money and fiat money is
not hard money so that that's just not a
threat this on an attack vector it's not
a threat vector and plus we had now have
plenty of Bitcoin billionaires and multi
billionaires who have tremendous
lobbying influence in Washington okay
and well either direct billionaires or
associate or affiliated with billion
billionaires so Peter Thiel for example
is a billionaire he's part of the PayPal
get a mob as I call it you know and and
so he's got tremendous influence at
least I know he did a couple years ago I
believe he still does then you have just
a lot of other folks in that circle
that have you know billions of dollars
and they have the ability to change laws
you know America is kind of one of the
cheapest countries in the world in terms
of graft you can get a law changed in
America for a hundred thousand bucks you
know it's I wish our senators were more
corrupt and that they would cost more to
change laws or or to create new laws to
tell you the truth but they seem to be
open to pretty nickel and diming you can
get a lot changed in a heartbeat this is
why you know the financial sector they
overturned every single regulation since
1933 1934 the Securities Act you know
well because you took a series 7 exam so
you know those those laws every single
thing in the securities laws Act of 33
and 34 has been overturned by lobbyists
from Wall Street in Washington so now
none of those protections exist anymore
and we have a situation that we have now
that they just try to meet every single
problem by printing money the money's
being debased it's backed by nothing or
as Paul Krugman of the New York Times
says the US dollars backed by men with
guns okay great well if you can't pay
the men with guns anymore what happens
to your currency it goes you know
hyperinflationary collapsed to zero so
you know this is this is the sad state
of affairs that fiat money is not going
to breed a solid political economic
class representing solid values that
people are going to look up to know it's
disintegrating before our eyes
Patrick it's disintegrating before our
eyes and I cannot believe the fact that
people don't kill with us constant
printing money mother was just pathetic
to me that it just keeps happening over
and over and over again we keep talking
about how quantitative easing is not the
way to go but we keep doing it over and
over again to last whatever 15 20 years
let me ask you a question
you're an insurance business okay it's
all works on spreads sure if they go to
negative interest rates so what happens
to your industry you already know what
happens to many insurance carriers many
insurance carriers cannot be accepting
more business if they go that route okay
well you know why they do negative rates
cuz they're bailing out corrupt banks no
one else using that
it's pathetic right so why so so I'm
saying bitcoin is you know get your
50,000 agents to start selling Bitcoin
well here your customers a favor turn it
around let's turn it around Patrick I'm
gonna make you a billion dollars I've
got two ways to make you a billion
dollars number one put bitcoin into the
mix of products there's agents are
selling number one number two I've got
an idea for an insurance product that'll
make you a billion dollars and I hope
you remember me by giving me a
commission when you catch that billion
dollar check
[Music]